[Music]
cold skull island hits theaters next
month and this could be the biggest
baddest Kong ever the movie stars Golden
Globe winner Tom Hiddleston and Oscar
winner brie Larson and only we can take
you to the set
he is truly monstrous in size and scale
and scope he's 90 feet tall Kong Skull
Island is set in 1973 at the end of the
Vietnam War and Hiddleston and Larson
are part of the team
tracking the giant a were captivated by
Kong's power and majesty he is the
mystery of the unknown he is a
terrifying force of nature with an
intelligence we don't understand an
unlike pass
King Kong movies Bri doesn't play the
typical damsel in distress she's a
photographer I've taken enough photos of
mass graves to recognize one it's huge
and we're talking about one of the
greatest myths of all time I couldn't
resist the stars shot on location in
Australia Hawaii and Vietnam Lasher
during award season the Best Actress
Golden Globe sag and Oscar winner for
room had to improvise her red carpet
looks with her stylist from the remote
set I'm working I'm filming King Kong
I'm spending my days running around in
the jungle with no phone signals Oh
I have the time I have no service to try
and find a dress good a monkey
maybe the most thrilling action rugged
and war exciting